Simone Sanders saying that but she used
to be Bernie Sanders communications
director back during the 2016 campaign
and the fact that she said I think the
beginning that she said I'm trying to
keep myself from laughing
at Joe's question about why you know why
aren't there going to be debates or are
there going to be debates like they
really think it's a joke and that's what
they think this is Joe Scarborough or
Joe Scarborough Joe Scarborough asking
the question
who was he asking he was asking you can
just play it played a clip the
Democratic side Bobby Kennedy Jr
doing well he's at 19
hasn't really gotten that that much out
there I mean it's and I'm starting to
hear more and more talk
about him are we going to actually have
a challenge here I'm trying not to laugh
Joe there's not going to can I just
I just stop you for a second
here we go
Donald Trump in 2015.
same exactly yeah because there was
going to be a Republican primary but I
really think that uh the mealy mouth
Democrats as I like to call them and
some of my Progressive friends who would
like to live in a fantasy land they need
to come back to reality and the reality
is this the sitting president of the
United States of America is a Democrat a
Democrat that would like to run for
re-election so much so that he has
declared a re-election campaign in that
case the Democratic National Committee
will not facilitate a primary process
there will be no debate stage for Bobby
Kennedy Marine Wood Marianne Williamson
or anyone else so we're going to have
another Bobby Kennedy and an empty chair
and a debate right there will be no baby
yeah
committee administers the debates and
they're not going to set up a primary
process for debates too for someone to
challenge the head of the democratic
party so here's what I hope Bobby
Kennedy does is is goes to you guys goes
to Joe Rogan and goes to multiple people
who have platforms and say will you host
a debate invite Joe Biden invite
Marianne Williamson and let him not show
up they're they're her the keywords
there she says they have to come to
reality and what is the reality that the
DNC believes that they are the Arbiters
of democracy
and they will decide if there's no
debates then there will be no debates
well guess what there's a whole country
out here that's actually interested the
fact that Bobby Kennedy is what I think
he's north of 20 now he hasn't even been
in a campaign for a month at this point
the fact that Joe Biden has such low
approval their their less than 30
percent of Democrats people want him to
run and yet they're saying there will be
no debate because of the DNC there's a
lot of folks out there who would like to
hear more and learn more and I hope that
that Bobby Kennedy and uh creates that
opportunity and invites Joe Biden to
show up I think that's a brilliant idea
I think we might want to implement that
strategy Pat question for you Tulsi I
mean I think it's disgusting that
they're just kind of hiding Joe Biden in
a basement it's almost sort of like a
Weekend at Bernie's type of thing
they're just going to string them out
there but at the same time if you look
at the Republican primary Trump has in
so many words said that he probably
won't even show up to the RNC debates do
you think Trump
you know Trump just did this CNN Town
Hall that I don't know that DeSantis
would agree to do a CNN I don't know
maybe he would maybe he wouldn't but uh
for every debate that I've seen Trump
has done very well oh no I don't know
but no I mean I think I think that
um
I think that he would probably do well
and I think the voters uh would
appreciate being able to have candidates
there on the stage obviously it's up to
him it'll make a decision but
um I think it would send a strong
statement is it fair to say
you know 2016 you were Bernie 2020
Biden you endorse Biden if it were Trump
Biden again in 2024 How likely is it
that you would vote for Trump this time
around
I will not be supporting Joe Biden under
any circumstances
you know that what happened in 2016 or
2020 rather at that point was
um you know the race on the Democratic
primary side had had virtually been
decided and uh I've known Joe Biden for
a long time and I felt uh that he the
The Joe Biden I knew was a good-hearted
man who had the best of intentions uh
for the country and so I had hoped that
he would listen to his better angels and
provide the kind of leadership uh that
our country needed unfortunately he has
proven
um
that to be wrong I mean that that that
uh that that hope unfortunately never
never came about and and I think uh
obviously he is the president he is
responsible he is accountable the people
he has surrounded himself with uh are uh
more divisive uh more destructive of
pushed us to the brink of World War III
and nuclear war from a domestic policy
and a foreign policy standpoint have
been uh
have had a destructive effect on our
country that I'm concerned if they were
to continue and be re-elected uh it
would take us to a place that perhaps
you could not come back from number one
and number two before long we would we
would have a president Kamala Harris as
commander-in-chief which which I and
others who wear the uniform find to be
uh scary beyond belief so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
foreign